Many sci-fi fans have long hoped for a version of
"Dune" that would do greater visual and narrative
justice to Frank Herbert's work. Now, director
Denis Villeneuve has been drafted to bring it
to the big-screen. Here's everything we know
about the 2021 adaptation of “Dune” so far.
The road to making a new cinematic
version of "Dune" was lengthy even
before the current roster of talent signed
on for the film. Director Denis Villeneuve,
who'd long hoped to helm a new adaptation of
the novel, signed on to make the film in 2017.
However, it wasn't until two years later that
the project actually landed a 2020 release date.
Then the COVID-19 pandemic hit, making a 2020
release for "Dune" very unlikely and leaving
Warner Bros. to make some new moves. In October of
2020, Warner Bros. announced that the film would
shift to October 1, 2021. Then, in December,
the studio dropped some even bigger news.
Its entire 2021 film slate, including "Dune,"
would also simultaneously premiere on the HBO
Max streaming service, giving viewers a chance
to watch the film at home without waiting.
“It’s time.”
Any "Dune" adaptation faces a monumental challenge
in assembling a cast to fill Herbert's universe.
It starts with finding the perfect actors to
stand in the center of it all as the Atreides
family. In 2018, Oscar nominee Timothée
Chalamet joined the film as Paul Atreides,
making Dune his first blockbuster role. Shortly
after reports of Chalamet's involvement started
circulating, Rebecca Ferguson joined the film
as Paul's mother, the Bene Gesserit woman Lady
Jessica. She first begins teaching him the gifts
that will later manifest as messianic abilities.
With the two most prominent members of House
Atreides in place, it was time for the film
to cast Duke Leto Atreides. This is Paul's
father who brings his family to Arrakis to
take over leadership of the planet, and finds
only trouble. In early 2019, it was revealed
that Duke Leto would be played by Oscar Isaac, who
adds another major sci-fi franchise to his resume
just a few years after joining the "Star Wars"
galaxy. These three actors form the core family
unit that is House Atreides, but they're
far from the only major stars in the film.
"Dune" is an epic novel spanning several years
and featuring two major royal houses, Atreides and
Harkonnen, who battle each other for supremacy on
the planet. One that also includes its own native
race, the Fremen. That means a massive cast
needed to be assembled to make the film work.
Because this is a Denis Villeneuve film adaptation
of one of the most beloved genre novels ever,
A-list actors have lined up to make the supporting
cast for "Dune" a truly all-star ensemble.
Among the stars assembled to round out
the film's cast are Stellan Skarsgard,
Jason Momoa, Javier Bardem, Zendaya, Josh
Brolin, David Dastmalchian, Dave Bautista,
and Charlotte Rampling. It's an exciting,
diverse roundup of some of the most
acclaimed actors working right now in both
action blockbusters and prestige dramas.
It’s exactly the right blend for Herbert's
sprawling space opera of warring dynasties.
"Dune" is one of the most celebrated
and influential science fiction novels
ever written. First published in 1965, Frank
Herbert's novel is set amid a future civilization
built on a kind of interplanetary feudal system.
There's a central government led by an Emperor,
and various planets are controlled by his
vassals, which take the title of Baron or Duke.
The main action of "Dune" takes place on
the planet Arrakis. It’s one of the most
important fiefdoms in the Empire because its vast
deserts contain "the spice," an addictive and
valuable substance. The novel follows the
Atreides family as they are given control
of Arrakis by the Emperor, only to find that a
vast plot to overthrow them is already underway.
Amid these political struggles, Duke Leto
Atreides' young son, Paul, begins to manifest
superhuman abilities that make him a messiah
figure among the local Fremen. A rebellion
begins, and Paul's abilities make him into a
leader fit to challenge the Emperor himself.
“My lord, Duke.”
Of course, Herbert's novel is
much more complicated than that,
and after "Dune" he just kept going. Herbert
himself wrote five sequels to the novel
and concluded his series with "Chapterhouse:
Dune" in 1985, but the story didn't end there.
Herbert's son Brian picked up the torch from
his father and, with novelist Kevin J. Anderson,
has published more than a dozen more "Dune" books,
many of them prequels to the original novel.
The earliest attempts to adapt
Dune for the screen kicked off
just a few years after the novel was published.
In the mid-1970s, director Alejandro Jodorowsky
launched a tremendously ambitious
effort to bring the novel to the screen.
The project involved everyone from Orson Welles to
Salvador Dalí to Pink Floyd. Jodorowsky eventually
abandoned the project when the financing
for the film could not be fully realized,
but his efforts were later chronicled in
the 2013 documentary "Jodorowsky's Dune."
The post-"Star Wars" era improved the
fortunes of "Dune" as a movie. So,
in 1984 a big-screen version helmed by director
David Lynch was finally released, starring Kyle
MacLachlan as Paul Atreides. Although it has since
become a cult film, "Dune" was a box office flop
and earned negative reviews. Lynch, not yet the
household name he would be after "Twin Peaks,"
was frustrated by a lack of creative control
and eventually disowned his "Dune" altogether.
A longer and more faithful adaptation of Herbert's
novel arrived on the small screen in 2000 as
"Frank Herbert's Dune." It’s a TV miniseries
written by John Harrison that aired in three
two-hour installments on the Sci-Fi Channel.
It was successful enough that a sequel, "Frank
Herbert's Children of Dune," followed in 2003 and
adapted the next two novels in Herbert's series.
Attempts to bring "Dune" back to the big screen
kicked into gear in 2008, when Paramount Pictures
announced Peter Berg would direct a new
adaptation. That effort eventually stalled,
and in 2016 Legendary Pictures announced that
they had landed the film and TV rights for "Dune."
Soon after Legendary's announcement that they
would be adapting "Dune" for the screen again,
reports began to circulate that director Denis
Villeneuve was the studio's choice to direct the
new film version. Villeneuve's involvement
was confirmed by Brian Herbert in 2017,
after he dazzled audiences with "Arrival"
but before "Blade Runner 2049" arrived in
theaters to critical acclaim. Thanks
to those two films in particular,
Villeneuve is one of the most important
voices in science fiction cinema right now.
He's a lifelong "Dune" fan who called the chance
to adapt the book the project of his life.
But he made it clear that he wouldn't be relying
on the Lynch film version at all. Villeneuve said,
"I mean, David Lynch is one of the best
filmmakers alive. I have massive respect
for him, but when I saw his adaptation, I was
impressed, but it was not what I had dreamed of,
so I'm trying to make the adaptation of my
dreams. It will not have any link with the
David Lynch movie. I'm going back to the book, and
going to the images that came out when I read it."
Frank Herbert's original novel is not the longest
genre epic you're likely to find on the shelves
at your local bookstores, but it is among the
most dense. "Dune" is a book absolutely packed
with plot, covering dozens of characters, multiple
groups and cultures, and a vast mythology — some
of which is only hinted at in the first novel.
It's the kind of book so full of detail that it
needs an appendix at the back so you can look
up various invented terms for more clarity.
That means adapting the book to the screen is
hard, particularly when you're working within
the constraints of a big-budget film. These
days that pretty much demands you weigh in
with a runtime of three hours or less. Even
with that in mind, though, adapting "Dune"
as one three-hour story is a daunting prospect
that's defeated filmmakers in the past.
So, for Villeneuve's film version, the solution
was obvious: don't try to make "Dune" one film.
Villeneuve made it clear that he was setting a
goal of two films for "Dune." In the summer of
2018, Brian Herbert confirmed that the screenplay
for the new film would adapt approximately half of
the first novel in the series. It's not clear
how far "approximately half" will take us,
but the novel does include a time jump to allow
Paul Atreides to age a bit at one point, so
it's possible the first film will leave off there.
Brian Herbert confirmed in 2018 that
Villeneuve's desire to split "Dune"
into two films had come to fruition, and that
the film we'd see first would only adapt half
the novel. This was reaffirmed in the spring
of 2019 by Legendary Pictures CEO Joshua Grode,
who added a little context as to
why the split happened. He shared,
"There's a backstory that was hinted at in
some of the books [that we expanded]. Also,
when you read the book there's a logical place
to stop the movie before the book is over."
There's one really interesting
wrinkle in all of this, though.
Yes, "Dune" will be split into two films,
but it's not like "The Lord of the Rings."
Peter Jackson shot all of
those movies back-to-back,
but Villeneuve is not making one "Dune" film
right after the other. Instead, Legendary seems
to be waiting to see how the first film fares
before launching into production on a sequel.
This adds intrigue to what Villeneuve said when
he first discussed his two-movie plan. He said,
"'Dune will probably take two years to make.
The goal is to make two films, maybe more."
So far, the only adaptation we've gotten beyond
Herbert's first novel is the "Children of Dune"
miniseries. However, if Villeneuve has his way we
could one day see a film version of other books.
After years of anticipation, the
first official trailer for "Dune"
arrived in September of 2020. This was
back when Warner Bros. was still holding
out hope that the film might make it into
theaters that December. That, of course,
didn't happen. But the trailer still managed
to capture the hearts and imaginations of fans,
raising the anticipation level for the film
more than a year before its eventual release.
The first trailer is much more of a teaser than
a full plot breakdown. It spends much of its time
with Paul Atreides as he grapples with visions
of what might happen to him and his family as
they head for the desert planet of Arrakis. We
see him tested, tormented, and doing his best to
be strong even as the dangers of the planet
become apparent. The trailer is, of course,
packed with dazzling visuals, leading up
to the reveal of a sandworm at the end.
The second official trailer, released in the
summer of 2021, digs more heavily into the plot
and the supporting cast of the film, and pays
particular attention to Chani, the Fremen girl
Paul eventually falls in love with. In this
trailer we get a much better sense of the plot.
Paul begins to realize not only that his family
is in grave danger from the evil Harkonnens,
but that he himself might not actually be the
person to lead House Atreides into the future.
It's a much fuller view of the film,
one that allows us to see more of the
internal dynamics of the ensemble, as
well as some great action sequences.
“Get everything with guns off the ground. Go”
Not all were happy when WarnerMedia announced
“Dune” would simultaneously premiere in
theaters and on the HBO Max streaming service,
including "Dune" director Denis Villeneuve.
In a statement released to Variety at the time,
Villeneuve blasted Warners' parent company,
AT&T. He explained that he learned
about the release plans, quote,
"in the news" like everyone else. He wrote,
"With this decision AT&T has hijacked one of
the most respectable and important studios in
film history. There is absolutely no love
for cinema, nor for the audience here."
Though Villeneuve was not the only
critic of the release strategy,
he has remained among the loudest. In an
August 2021 interview with “Total Film,”
he called the move ridiculous and regarding
watching "Dune" on a home TV, said,
"[It’s like] driv[ing] a
speedboat in your bathtub."
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about
upcoming movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.